let's talk about this it's a great story
because Florence Foster Jenkins came out
and people the critics went insane for
this movie they have now rereleased it
for awards season which i think is
really smart yeah because it is a
fantastic movie thank you and it's you
Hugh Grant Meryl Streep yeah I mean
that's got to be blowing your mind that
you got in that movie yeah it was three
of you it's the three of us I just yeah
I moved to London for a summer and and
went to work with Meryl Streep and Hugh
Grant and I almost landed in the
hospital from just anxiety attacks but I
you know I I found out that Hugh who is
so debonair and charming also panics all
the time and he had something called I
think a panic sack or something which
you know when you meet a man for the
first time and he starts talking about
his panic sack you know you want to run
the other way yeah yeah but he's British
so yeah yeah what's in his panic sack
what is it Oh thought you'd never ask
something like that well well you can
yes yes and he did right over my way
this is a show primarily for children
well our culture is dwindling um yeah so
he he gets he gets very nervous - so he
but he seems so cool and and he started
to tell me that he he carries this
Rescue Remedy around with him which is
like a naturopathic it's like one of
those things that it has like you know
like the elderflower root and the
dandruff of a wizard or something it out
like memories of a buddhist dwarf or it
imbued and it's just it's nothing it's
water right but you like put it on your
tongue and anyone they're supposed to
call me Dad and he was just like you
know like and before it sounds like oh
my god like here crazy but meanwhile my
wife had given me all of these little
like cocaine vials of essential oils and
they look big it's not good that you
said cocaine vials of essential oil well
I got cocaine
and that really set out me down for
anxiety like good old natural Pathak
right okay but you know those like vials
in the interview visa right but I was in
my dressing room and like they'd knock
on the door get me and I'd have this by
and I'd be like lathering myself in
patchouli because you're supposed to put
it on your like chakras and it's
supposed to calm you and so I was we
went to the table read and Hugh was like
all dosed up on you know wizard water
and I was all oily lathered up sitting
like hey Merrill you have a great time
doesn't matter I have a lot of oil all
over my body
you